in the last video I showed that the
Laplace transform of T or could view
that as T to the first power is equal to
1 over s squared if we assume that s is
greater than 0 in this video we're going
to see what we can generalize this by
trying to figure out the Laplace
transform of T to the N where n is any
integer power greater than 0 so n is any
positive integer greater than 0 so let's
try it out so we know from our
definition of the Laplace transform that
the Laplace transform of T to the N is
equal to the integral from 0 to infinity
from 0 to infinity of our function well
let me write T to the N times and this
is just the definition of the transform
e to the minus s T DT and similar to
when we figured out this Laplace
transform your intuition might be that
hey we should use integration by parts
and I showed it in the last video I
always forget it but I just recorded it
so I do happen to remember it so the
integration by parts just tells us that
the integral of U V prime is equal to UV
minus the integral of
iview this is the kind of the swap so u
prime u prime V so this is just our
integration by parts formula if you ever
forget it you can derive it in about 30
seconds from the product rule now I did
it in the last video because I hadn't
used it for a while so I had to read
arrive it so let's apply it here so what
do we want to make our V prime it's
always good to use the exponent
exponential function because that's easy
to take the antiderivative of so this is
our V prime which in which case our V is
just the antiderivative of that so it's
e to the minus st over minus s all right
if we take the derivative of this minus
s divided by minus s cancels out you
just get that and then if we make if we
make our you let me pick a good color
here if we make this equal to ru what's
our u prime u prime is just going to be
n times T to the N minus 1 fair enough
so let's
apply the integration by parts so this
is going to be equal to UV u R this is T
to the N so u is T to the N that's R u
times V which is e let me write this
down so it's e - there's a minus sign
there so let me put the - let me do it
in that color
- just rewriting this e to the minus s T
over s and okay so that's the UV term
right there let me make that clear let
me pick a good color here so this term
right here is this term right here and
of course this isn't I'm going to have
to evaluate this from 0 to infinity so
let me write that 0 to infinity I could
put a little bracket there or something
but you know we're gonna have to
evaluate that and then from that we're
going to have to subtract the integral
and let me not forget our boundaries 0
to infinity of u prime u prime is n
times T to the N minus 1 that's our u
prime times V times minus e to the
months let me put this minus out here so
minus e to the minus s T over s and then
all of that of course we have our DT and
you have a minus - these things become
pluses and let's see if we can simplify
this a little bit so we get our Laplace
transform of T to the N is equal to this
evaluated at infinity and evaluated at 0
so when you evaluate what's the limit of
this as T approaches infinity as T
approaches infinity this term you might
say oh this becomes really big and I
went over this in the last video but
this term overpowers it because you're
going to have e to the minus infinity if
we assume that s is greater than 0 so if
s is greater than 0 this term is going
to win out and go to 0 much faster than
this term is going to go to infinity so
when you in value ate it in infinity
when you in value ate this and infinity
you're going to get 0
and then you're going to subtract this
evaluated at zero this evaluated at zero
when it evaluated at zero is just minus
zero to the N times e to the minus s
times zero over s well this becomes zero
as well so this whole term evaluated
from zero to infinity is all zero which
is nice convenient thing for us and then
we're going to have this next term right
there so let's take out the constant
terms this N and this s are constant
they're constant respect with respect to
T so you have plus n over s times the
integral from 0 to infinity of T to the
N minus 1 times e to the minus s T DT
now this should look reasonably familiar
to you this should look reasonably
what's the definition of the Laplace
transform the Laplace transform of any
function is equal to the integral from 0
to infinity of that function times e to
the minus stdt well we have an e to the
minus stdt we're taking the integral
from 0 to infinity so this whole
integral is equal to the Laplace
transform of this of T to the N minus 1
so just that easily because this term
went to 0 we have a we've simplified
things we get we get the Laplace
transform of T to the N is equal to this
all 0 it's equal to n over s that's
right there times this integral right
here which we just figured out was the
Laplace transform of T to the N minus 1
well this is a nice neat simplification
we can now figure out the Laplace
transform of a higher power in terms of
the one power lower than that but it
still doesn't give me a generalized
formula so let's see if we can use this
with this information to get a
generalized formula so the Laplace
transform of just T so let me write that
down I wrote
the beginning of the problem we get the
Laplace transform I could write this as
T to the 1 which is just T is equal to 1
over s squared where s is greater than
where s is greater than 0 now what
happens if we take the Laplace transform
Laplace transform of T squared well we
can just use this formula appear the
Laplace transform of T squared is equal
to 2 over s times the Laplace transform
of T of just of just t to the 1 right 2
minus 1 so times the Laplace transform
of T to the 1 well T we know what that
is
this is equal to 2 over s times this
times 1 over s squared which is equal to
2 over s to the third interesting let's
see if we can do another one
what is I'll do it in the dark blue the
Laplace transform of T to the third well
we just use this formula up here it's n
over s in this case n is 3 so it's 3
over s times the Laplace transform of n
to the T to the N minus 1 so T squared T
squared we know what the Laplace
transform of this one was this is just
this right there so it's equal to 3 over
s times times this thing and I'm gonna
actually write it this way because I
think it's interesting so I'll write the
numerator times 2 times 1 over s over s
squared which is we can write it as 3
factorial over what is this s to the
fourth power s to the fourth power let's
do another one I think you you already
are getting the idea of what's going on
Laplace transform of T to the fourth
power is what it's equal to 4 over s
times the Laplace transform of T to the
third power and that's just 4 over s
times this is 4 over s times 3 factorial
over s to the fourth so now for time
three factorial that's just four
factorial over s to the fifth and so you
can just get a general I general
principle we can prove this by induction
it's almost trivial based on what we've
already done that the Laplace transform
the Laplace transform of T to the N is
equal to n factorial n factorial over s
to the n plus 1 we tried it out for it
we proved it directly for this base case
right here right this is one factorial
over s to the 1 plus 1 and then for if
we know if we know it's true for this we
know it's going to be true for the next
increment so an induction proof is
almost obvious but you can even see it
based on this you have to figure out the
Laplace transform of T to the tenth you
could just keep doing this over and over
again but I think you see the pattern
pretty clearly so anyway I thought that
was a neat problem in of itself yeah you
don't you know outside of the fact that
will be useful when we figure out
inverse and Laplace transforms but this
is a pretty neat result the Laplace
transform of T to the N where n is some
integer greater than 0 is equal to n
factorial over s to the n plus 1 where s
is also greater than 0 that was an
assumption we have to make on early on
when we took our limits as as T
approaches infinity anyway hopefully you
found that useful